there's something brewing in German beer
glasses the craft beer movement is
gaining momentum especially here in
Berlin we aren't a riverboat cruise to
celebrate the start of Berlin Beer Week
there are 49 different craft beer types
on offer here
most of them brewed in Berlin Berlin
it's the capital of the German craft
beer movement but don't the German
already have enough of different kinds
of beer they drink every year 8 billion
litres of beer and there are so many
different types to choose from so why do
we need craft beer especially since it's
more expensive some brews would cost up
to 6 euros a glass in a store mica meets
up with Stefan Kaluga one of the
founders of Berlin be awake Stefan says
we need even more craft beer
why is that traffic via I think a lot of
beer here in Germany is totally boring
sure the quality is good and there are
lots of good and excellent breweries
that produce traditional kinds of beer
they do a perfect job of it but they
haven't tried anything new for centuries
the cruise boat is an excellent place to
try out a large number of craft beers
but don't worry you only get to try a
sip of each kind they don't want anyone
going overboard so to speak craft beer
fans from all over the world are
attending the event including beer
sommelier of Lena Annika corn she's
expecting a baby so this time she's
sticking to alcohol-free beer right now
we have around 20 commercial craft beer
brewers they don't all own a brewery so
they rent a facility from someone else
to brew their product the number is
increasing so there's a real craft brew
scene here in Berlin what percentage of
the beer drunk in Germany is actually
craft beer it's almost impossible to say
we don't really know what craft beer is
here in Germany in the US they have a
clear definition that doesn't apply here
in Germany do we include the mid-sized
breweries that do everything themselves
or only those that brew India Pale Ales
but at a guess I'd say around 1% but a
growing number of breweries are
introducing craft beer to German beer
drinkers new small startups begin
brewing every year
one of them is Barlow in Berlin's
Kreuzberg district it gets its name from
the Slavic word for swamp it already has
an excellent reputation amongst
connoisseurs the container building was
designed by the famous graft architects
office this is no run-of-the-mill
brewery here the name of the game isn't
tradition but creativity and handicraft
skills the beer is only brewed in small
quantities around 50% is for export some
ingredients have an unusual aroma and
the prices in the brewery restaurant are
not to be sneezed at so what's your
latest experiment and why is the beer so
expensive right now we're experimenting
with different fruits and spices like
Chile we use costly aroma hops that are
later added to the beer in large
quantities we have a large variety if
you always brew the same beer and use
the same yeast and just press a button
well then that is a good deal cheaper
the official festival beer this year is
made with Earl Grey tea we're back on
the riverboat some craft beer brewers
adhere to the German purity law although
they don't have to but as adding things
like tea Herald the end of five hundred
years of strict content regulation on
the country it fits well together you
can brew interesting beers and still
stick to the rules most kinds of beer
only need the four basic ingredients and
the purity law ensures the beer is of
premium quality and that's what craft
beer is all about - everyone here agrees
that craft beer is a high quality
product time now for a small test will
the craft beer crowd managed to spot a
normal Berlin beer
[Music]
you gotta speed this up
[Music]
they all managed to spot the odd man out
in the moment the people here in Germany
are talking more about craft beer than
drinking it but the people here on the
ship belief that very soon in every good
restaurant there will be not only a wine
list but also a beer menu and in any
case it's a good addition to the good
old German beer culture
[Music]